(audience applauds)
- We are back with Chris
Pratt, Charlie Day,
Keegan-Michael Key, and Jack Black!
Give it up!
(audience cheers)
Their new movie is called the
Super Mario Brothers movie.
It's in theaters everywhere in April.
Alright, well, Chris, you
had a run in with bees
since I saw you last.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There was a very funny video online.
So tell everybody what happened.
- There's this wonderful
person on Instagram.
I wish I knew. It's Texas
Bee Lady or something.
- Of course she's from Texas. Okay.
- Please when you-
(Keegan-Michael laughs)
- Of course.
- I want to give her the
credit that it's due.
She's fantastic. I love
watching her on Instagram.
You guys follow this gal?
She like has the most amazing demeanor.
I can't think of her name right now,
so put it on the screen or something.
It's this. This is her name.
- [Kelly] (laughs) Up here.
- And if you act fast...
(Kelly claps)
But it's this gal
(Jack laughs)
and she's like very calm in her voice
and she's like, "Today
I saw a hive of bees
in the floor of a baseball dugout."
And she takes out the floor and
there's like 4 million bees.
She knows, she just reaches
in there with her hands
and they're all over her
and she finds the queen
and puts it in a hair clip.
I'll watch, I go like a
k-hole of this Bee Lady
for like four hours watching her video.
She's fantastic and-
- It's amazing they let
her touch the queen.
- It is.
No, and then she'll put it away
and then she moves them all.
They just love her.
They never sting her. She's cool.
So I, of course, watch
four hours of these videos.
I'm like, "I got this down."
And we were looking at a house,
this house that was for sale.
We went to go tour it and
just saw this big beehive.
And the real estate agent
was like, "Hey, careful,
there's a big beehive over there."
I'm like, (laughs) "We're okay."
(audience laughs)
(Kelly chuckles)
I was like, "Yeah, they
do look like honeybees."
(guests laugh)
And they're like, (imitates bees buzzing)
I was like, trust me, if
you're calm they won't.
(Chris shouts)
(guests laugh)
Then it stung me right in
the eyeball, like right here.
I was like, oh. (shouts)
(Jack laughs)
And so there it is.
You can see my eye there.
She got me good
and then I was like I think
I may have jokingly said
like (beep) the Bee Lady in the video.
And then she roasted me
in the comments section.
And anyways, we're kind of friends.
- [Kelly] Oh my god. That's amazing.
- [Keegan-Michael] You guys
are kind of friends now.
- No, I don't know.
She, after roasting me, she
hasn't returned my calls.
- [Kelly] It's fine.
- She seems really-
Give her a follow.
She's actually really fantastic.
She's a really cool gal.
- I do think it's incredible
when people do stuff like that.
- Oh my gosh, yeah she's-
- But she should say, "Don't
try this at home, Chris Pratt."
- I think she does.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think she probably. (laughs)
- Please don't follow any
like snake or bear people.
- Yeah.
- Yes. (laughs)
- You know, because.
- That's gonna go bad.
- You're like the little
boy that watched Peter Pan.
Like watch this mom and you're
like flying from the roof.
(guests laughing)
- No, I have an umbrella.
I'll be fine. (shouts) Oh my god!
- Mary Poppins did it. Yeah.
(laughs) That's amazing.
Well Charlie, speaking of
wildlife, you found a random cat.
So let's see that.
- I did.
Like we have footage?
Is your cat black?
(playful music)
Does your cat have a
white stripe on its noses?
Does your cat have no microchip
and a complete set of testicles?
Then maybe your cat is this cat.
I got your cat.
- Got your cat.
- I got your cat.
(audience cheers)
(all laugh)
- Did you? That's the most amazing ad.
So wait, did you find the owner?
- Yeah, that's my cat now. Yeah. Yeah.
That cat lives with me.
- Oh you now own the cat.
It was a stray.
- There was no microchip,
couldn't find an owner
and that cat has lived with
me for almost two years now.
That cat has been named Oreo.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- By my son.
That cat rules the house and the dogs
and the cat's in charge.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's cats for you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're moving out but
the cat's staying there.
(all laughing)
- Jack, this is not
wildlife but it looks wild.
What's happening in this photo, sir?
- [Jack] Oh.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Okay, so-
- It's a lot happening.
I know that's Madonna.
- You know what happened?
- Is that Lil Wayne?
- [Jack] Yeah, Lil Wayne.
And that's Larry over on the other side.
You know what happened was my wife
and I were invited over to a dinner.
- [Kelly] Is this what happens
when you get invited
to dinner with people?
- Yeah we went over to the dinner.
We thought we're just going
to have a nice little quiet dinner.
And then at the end of the dinner
it was announced Madonna was going
to play truth or dare and
we're going to film it.
So anyone who wants to join, no pressure,
anyone who wants to
join the truth or dare.
And I was like I'm not going
to do the truth or dare.
And my wife said, "What
are you talking about?
It's Madonna, you have to go."
I was like, okay.
I got permission from my wife
to play Truth or Dare with Madonna.
(Kelly laughs)
And the next thing you know,
we're like making crazy photographs.
- [Kelly] You're trying
to edit it for game time?
(guests laugh)
- Just a lot went down
and I had permission.
Okay?
- Your wife was cheering you on.
I love it. (laughs)
It's special relationship.
(guests laugh)
That's amazing.
- You can't say no to Madonna.
(Keenan-Michael laughs)
- You didn't. (laughs)
- [Jack] I did not.